here now with more on his big release
House Judiciary Committee ranking member
Doug Collins first thank you we wouldn't
know so much that we know but for your
courage to release these closed-door
testimony documents what did you take
out of yesterday beyond about Loretta
Lynch have so much more
well thanks Sean I think one of the
things that John just talked about is
the American people are turning because
they're seeing the truth for the first
time they're actually seeing these
testimonies that the investigators did
and you saw that with with my colleagues
with Ratcliffe and Jordan and meadows
and others who did this we're seeing the
truth of Gowdy what they found out was
is that there was a conflict what they
were finding out was that there's this
cover-up because they knew that if it
was ever uncovered that there would be
trouble Lynch we knew was that basically
we've already seen the incompetence that
she showed his Attorney General now
we're seeing them turning on Jim Comey
who this his his little run is Captain
America is coming to an end he is not
what he has betrayed himself to be and
there's gonna be answering for that
based on what we see in these
transcripts there's contradictions at
every turn well what do you make it John
Solomon's report we we know the Bruce or
warning we know this woman ten days
before the first physical location
warned all these upper echelon again not
rank and file not the 99% very important
and they were warned in so many
different ways they had probably ten
times the amount of evidence that was
exculpate or II including transcripts
we're gonna hear about as John said in
the next week or so within the next week
and they never listened to it why
because it was what they I think they'd
had a pattern all the time Sean we've
talked about this before this is a
corrupt cabal of the top leadership who
did not like Canada Trump they
definitely didn't like the thought of a
president Trump and now though thingy
was doing is they were covering for
themselves they had what they believe I
think was their insurance policy they
believed what they had was going to be
the investigation that would show that
there was a problem and what really is
disturbing here is they knew that they
had a problem that they was with these
you know information that we're getting
from still in this dossier and yet they
went with it as you said earlier Comey
but verified this in the FISA
application but yet just a few months
later said they were very unverified
installations we still have that today
that's the thing that's interesting here
they've never been verified this is the
problem that we're having bunkers
they're turning on each other now and
now look at this basically the Attorney
General under Obama Lynch basically
accusing the FBI director at the time of
perjury congressman this is so important
what you're doing thank you we
appreciate it congressman Collins from
Georgia